bring in Tom Verducci MLB Network
insider Sports Illustrated senior
baseball writer and the Astros are on
the clock right now Tom what are the
Astros accused of well they're accused
of using electronics specifically a
camera in center field to steal signs we
all know that feeling signs is part of
the game and it's mutual agreement that
if you do so in the course of you know
the natural events of the game runner on
second base you see the pitcher is
tipping his pitches by the way he grips
the ball people don't have a problem
with that it's when you introduce
devices and schemes that there's
definitely a problem both ethically and
in today's game actually illegally
because Rob Manfred the commissioner and
MLB crack down on this before the season
began and basically said let's crack
down the use of technology to steal sign
because I think it had been pretty
prevalent so there's definitely in
trouble here with the commissioner and
that the big news here is that you have
a player who was on the 2017 Astros
named on the record Mike fire saying
this is what we did back then and it was
wrong do you have any problem with fires
saying this not only do his teammates
but then eventually ken Rosenthal no I
don't that may he made it clear that
once he went through both the Tigers and
the A's after he left usin that he has
to let his teammates know hey guys when
we go to Houston heads-up be extremely
careful with your signs things are going
on there so no I mean this is what
happens when if you are engaged in these
activities you run the risk that at some
point it's going to come to light and
it's taken a couple of years and I
should add that back at 2017 then we
didn't have these protocols in place
about the use of technology I mean it
was technology advanced at a faster pace
and animals be get their arms around
this that's why I can't slow down that's
why you heard about the use of Apple
watch and the Red Sox dugout they were
fine
the Astros themselves were fine for
surveilling the dugouts of the Indians
in the Red Sox so all this was going on
before the protocols were place and
they're quite specific this year about
putting the protocols and essentially
threatening
if you do violate it you are all going
to be disciplined but what kind of
punishment do you think the Commissioner
is going to hand down with the to the
Astros well it all depends if they can
identify intent and a specific person if
they find there's actually a specific
person who was running this scheme that
person literally has their baseball
career on the line I'm not saying this
rise until level of what got the death
penalty in terms of baseball career for
John capella the Braves GM with some of
the infractions regarding signing in
international creations but there's no
question here that there is intent that
someone specifically and intentionally
went outside of these rules that that
Manfred put in place that person could
be in jeopardy in terms of his life in
terms of his career in baseball
otherwise you're talking about
definitely fines we've seen that done
before the protocols were put in place
lots of draft pick which he has hinted
at would be a part of a discipline again
it all depends on how specific they can
nail this down in terms of intent and
individuals but if they find the guy
whose job was to bang on the garbage can
then they found their man do you think
that AJ Hinch the manager of the Astros
knew about this probably not I mean it's
possible that he did but I'm not saying
to be dead it takes me back the days of
the steroid era or people thought well
guys are using steroids so everybody
must have known well know when you're
engaged in these kind of activities you
do it and it cleanses and fashion so
that as few people know about it as
possible
now obviously Mike fiers knew about it
I'm assuming you know on the days he
wasn't pitching he was sitting there in
the dugout well wait a minute time if I
got AJ Hinch who's the manager and he's
here and somebody banging on a garbage
can the first thing I would say is hey
who's ever not gonna banging on the
garbage can knock it off again if the
Commissioner is going to come down at
individuals and not just the
organization he better have proof that
in fact the manager knew that that may
be tough to prove I don't think he's
going to cops it knowing that but I
understand that yes if you're anybody in
that dugout there and there was a
pattern of this going not on it seemed
like there was it would be hard not
have at least an overview of what was
going on great to talk to you Tom I saw
a couple articles where there's a couple
of big ticket items who could be traded
this offseason and one was mookie betts
I think Chris Bryant was another name
that's coming up the fact that Gerrit
Cole does he relocate to the west coast
maybe the Angels de Strasbourg stay with
the Nationals you got a handle on any of
that yet yeah well it's very difficult
for these big names to be trade
especially mookie betts there's no doubt
the Red Sox will look to trade him at
least see what the market is I just
don't think they could be satisfied I
mean they're trying to get their payroll
down and Mookie is a year away from what
he promises to be will be the use of
free agency so they're smart to at least
investigate but I mean go back to the
trade of Paul Goldschmidt last year and
actually Arizona did okay in that deal
but for the Boston Red Sox to get you
know decent value from Mookie Betts and
still contend I don't see that happening
again I think they'll explore it but I
think it's hard to do and yeah Gerrit
Cole is probably you're talking about
probably a January or February signing
but I think the Angels because they have
a need because that's home for him it's
just a great fit overall I think that is
the clubhouse leader but again that is
going to take a while to play out Tom
thank you as always
yeah thank them that's Tom Verducci for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on be our live or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]